ونحن نعلم بان المنطقه المنزوعه السلاح
بين الشمال والجنوب ستكون محصنه بشكل قوي
بحيث انه سيكون من الصعب على احد الطرفين
مهاجمه الثاني فاذا ارادت كوريا الشماليه
الاستعداد لشن الحرب ماذا سيحدث اول شيء
قد تراه عدد كبير من المدافع والصواريخ
التي ستنصب على الجنوب قادمه من مواقع
الشمال وحتى العاصمه سيول نفسها لن تكون
بمنا لانها تقع بالقرب من المنطقه منزوعه
السلاح اللافت ان منصات اطلاق الصواريخ
تقع على منحدرات في الجبال التي تحيط بل
وتعد المحيط الطبيعي للمناطق منزوعه
السلاح لهذا سيكون من الصعب على قوات
الجنوب ان ترسد اي نشاط لنقل اي من القطع
العسكريه في الشمال في تلك الاثناء ستكون
كوريا الشماليه قد ارسلت فرق العمليات
الخاصه عبر الغواصات كما ستقوم بتفعيل
الخلايا النائمه التي نعتقد انها موجوده
في الجنوب منذ فتره قد تزيد عن عقدين من
الزمان تلك الخلايا ستلعب دورا مهما في
تحديد الاهداف العسكريه داخل الجزء
الجنوبي وبالطبع فان الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه لن تقفا مكتوي الايدي
فماذا تتوقع ان تكون رده فعلهما اولا
الولايات المتحده ستعزز من حضور قوتها
البحريه ولا سما حامله الطائرات من اجل
حسم المعركه الجويه لدينا حاملات طائرات
في اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه وعلى الولايات
المتحده تحريك القطع لتكون قرب المناطق
التي تضم المواقع الهجوميه التي تستهدف
الجنوب لاحقا تعمل تلك الطائرات على سيطره
على منابع القياده الشماليه ليتم حسم
المعركه الجويه فوق الشمال